uh what do you want to go on next okay
can we talk about siren
okay why is siren what is siren what the
[ __ ] is that
i'm surprised you've heard of siren i
[ __ ] love cyrus you love sauron oh my
[ __ ] god that's why i
that's why i was like why is this here
because it's one of those like it's one
of those please explain the place
underground shonen jump manga that like
it didn't have very long run time did it
um it had like a good 100 chapters did
it it got cancelled that's right yeah it
didn't get
totaled i will tell you the plot okay so
um there's gonna be like a slight
spoiler but i feel like it's within the
first four chapters and i feel like it's
it's it's a big twist that i feel
um is what got me hooked into this manga
right so
um so it's that's the main i can't i
can't actually remember the character
names because it's been so long since
i've read it but it's this main
character and
uh he
i don't think there's anything too
special about him at the beginning he
runs a service where he solves he solves
problems right that's got nothing to do
with what happens right and so he sees
this girl
um it looks like she
she looks like she's going through some
issues or something so she he tries to
help her and in that process
he
he follows her and then he gets
transported with her to just this
new place he doesn't know where he is
right
um
yeah he basically gets issac right goes
to another world yeah yeah
he goes to another world
here yeah no he goes to another world
with this girl right
um and then they're in just in just in
this like barren wasteland and then they
get transported with a bunch of people
and it's kind of like the gans kind of
theme where where it's it's not like
it's not as brutal because it's like
shonen jump gans so it's not it's not
got like massive gore but like people
just start dying left right and center
right and for some reason she has like a
special psychic power that she uses to
survive so he kind of follows her right
and so in like fighting through this
kind of death game kind of barren
wasteland kind of thing
he
he like tries to figure out where the
[ __ ] he is how he got there and what the
[ __ ] going on right and then it's like
the big twist at the end of episode four
is that he goes on top of this like
like uh building that's just been like
laying like it's it's like uh what's
what i'm looking for
like abandoned or not not abandoned but
it's just like it's what's the world
where it's just like like it's been
years since this building's been
overgrown dilapidated dilapidated yeah
it's this the laptop building right and
he and he goes on it and then he sees
mount fuji right
and it's just he realizes that
for some reason he's in japan he's in a
city that is in complete ruins and the
apocalypse has happened and so he
doesn't know how he got there or where
he is that's right or
should i say it
okay i'm gonna say okay
or when he is
but i mean i guessed when you said that
he's in japan yeah yeah time thing yeah
i said it was dilapidated yeah i was
like okay well that's yeah that
would signal the passage of time yeah
yeah so so that i i guess i guess that
that spoils it but
but yeah i mean so what i love about
this is that
it's a shonen jump action manga that has
that has has a mystery core because the
core of this is him
going back to his own world or his own
time and kind of figuring out what the
[ __ ] happened how did it happen and in
that process like i'm that's that's all
i'm gonna say because in the process
there's so many twists and turns that
come from that and him trying to figure
out what's going on
um and it was just nice to see
like a shonen jump that has action in it
but also has this really mystery aspect
that keeps you coming back and just
keeps you like reading the next page
just to figure out what happens because
i feel like there's there's been shown a
jump with a mystery aspect for example
uh what's the one where they eat kids
again i promise no one promises
nevertheless i've been like promised
neverland and it's been like obviously
i've never heard people like me
described as what's the one where they
eat kids i mean what am i wrong i don't
know why i got it right away am i wrong
am i wrong i mean that's it
it's right that is what it is that is
what it is like shenanigans it's not the
one about the kids trying to escape it's
the one where the kids get eaten
like i i like i i like the fact that it
had a mystery aspect and also a battle
shonen aspect and i feel like it was so
underground because nobody [ __ ] read
it i think the problem with siren is
that it kind of came out at a time where
shonen jump was just absolutely stacked
where like everything else in china
because this was like
mid-2000s shown in general right yeah so
this was not only in the midst of the
big three but also like the lesser-known
shonen jump stuff that was not the big
three was still very very popular so why
do they get cancelled then um just
because it wasn't popular enough yeah
i'm just like
i feel like i feel like another thing is
that unfortunately the art style just
looks so generic because this came off
the bleach it doesn't look like
the main character looks like ichigo
yeah yeah it kind of looks so generic
but it has so many original ideas like i
really like without supporting what the
main character's power is so like anyone
who goes to this world gets a special
power of their own right and i like as
an engineer
he has like a really unique power where
i'm not gonna spoil exactly what he is
but he can't control this power like he
can't
consciously control this power so what
he does
to kind of figure out a way different
ways to use his power is he makes
subroutines
for for this power so it's basically
like he makes programming loops for this
power to like follow a set algorithm to
do exactly what he wants
and i'm just like that's such a unique
idea it's like slowly remembering this
manga
man can type 2 000 words per minute
but yeah like i mean i could i could put
i could have put like hunter hunter or
other shonen jump manga on here yeah
it's nice to see some variation but yeah
like i said every every shonen jump
manga i can think of putting on here has
an anime adaptation so that's that's the
only reason why i put siren on here
because it's my it is my favorite shonen
jump manga that does not have an anime
yeah because it got cancelled because it
wasn't popular
the other one i would put on there is uh
did you ever read m0 i did not read it
okay that's another one that was like
kind of it came out around the same time
as siren where shannon jump was just
stacked never got an anime adaptation
but it's so good what's that about
m0 is about it's this basically it's
this kid who enters this magic school
but he himself has zero magic abilities
yeah so this is literally like think of
like [ __ ] my hero academia right but
instead of quirks it's magic power and
you have like certain levels of magic
and the higher your magic level is the
more powerful of like a magic card you
get that can like activate magic skills
and the main character again he has zero
magic so he gets an m0 card oh okay and
it's just him basically just trying to
basically survive and graduate yeah
magic school but like the art style is
so unique and it's so it's such a dope
solid story but again i've never got an
anime adaptation and like hardly anyone
read it because again
it jumped no it didn't get cancelled it
had a proper ending it got like 12
volumes or something oh and it had a
proper ending it just no one read it
because during that time shonen jump was
so stacked right all these other insane
shows it's stacked now as well stack now
but like mid 2000's shown in jump was
like so you can you can recommend it
even though it doesn't have an ending
exit oh no it has an ending it's just
very rushed uh but like
i can still recommend it because the
mystery aspect got solved and it got
solved in a decent amount of time what
didn't get what was like a bit
unsatisfying was just each character's
resolution because it got wrapped up so
quickly but the mystery aspect which was
the reason i was so addicted to is when
reading that gets wrapped up just fine
and that's why i can still recommend it